Carol Danvers,
prodigal child of the Milky Way.
Nick Fury,
my favorite one eyed man of intrigue.
How goes it out there?
I know.
Cold, no air space.
Captain Marvel being annihilated.
You took everything from me.
And now I'm returning the favor.
What is happening to me?
She's entangled our light based powers.
So we switch places whenever we use them.
Strong theory.
You can absorb light.
I can see it. And Kamala?
Who's Kamala? Hi.
She can turn light into a physical matter,
which I have never heard of.
I could totally show you.
No doubt.
But also percentile style profile.
She's targeting every planet we call home.
I would never choose
to bring anybody into this.
You are not the only thing
standing between this and the universe.
Oh, my God.
We're a team.
I'm going to
sound higher.
Just further and faster.
And that could give you
goose.
Yeah.
I can't. Can you?
I got it.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Happy Comic-Con Week!
Big surprise,
Marvel dropped the new The Marvels trailer
in the middle of the night.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of new footage,
bunch Easter eggs,
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're in the middle of secret invasion
episodes.
Secret Invasion
will lead into the beginning of Marvel's
I'm assuming
they'll be some kind of post-credits scene
that will explain
how Nick Fury goes back to his saber space
station, where he is in the trailer.
Maybe we'll get a cameo scene from Monica
Rambeau, who's working with him
as part of the Saber Organization,
running the space station.
because of that
Ms Marvel Post-Credits scene,
maybe they'll be like another post crazy.
They'll just carry forward
the Captain Marvel post-credit scene
where she shows up in Kamala Khan's house,
wondering how she got there
but it seems like based on the way
the trailer footage starts,
it starts before that takes place.
And he's just calling Captain Marvel
to catch up with what Carol Danvers
has been doing.
Big joke about being the prodigal daughter
of the Milky Way.
The Milky Way is our galaxy.
The earth belongs to.
she's mostly been increased girl space,
dealing with the Kree
and all the other planets.
Just trying to help random peoples
all over that part of the galaxy.
Really good example.
This is when Da Ben, played by Zoe
Ashton, who's actually the real life
wife of Tom Hiddleston, who plays Loki
also in the Marvel universe.
a lot more Marvel couples showing up.
she's the new leader of the free in
the absence of the supreme intelligence.
And the idea is that, Carol Danvers
killed the Supreme intelligence.
and that's what Da bin is talking about
when she says,
You took everything from us.
supposedly when the events of the movie
pick up, like years after the events
of the Captain Marvel movie,
the Kree people are doing terribly late.
Their race is in ruin.
Even though they were able to almost kill
off the skrulls they got rid of Skrulls.
That's why all the Skrulls came to Earth
after the five year time jump started
right after the snap, cleared up a bunch
of real estate for people to move in.
so even though they've been able
to pull that off up
to the beginning of Avengers
Infinity War, at some point things
just go really badly for their race in DA
Ben takes over leadership
and is looking for a way
to revitalize their race.
And she's using the second bangle
like Ms..
Marvel's other bangle that we kept
wondering about during the Ms.
Marvel series.
turns out they really are
saying they are the Kree Nega bands,
which basically turn thought into energy.
They're kind of like Green Lantern rings
in the Marvel Universe,
meaning that the blue hand in the temple
of the ten rings like big thing she Easter
egg actually belonged to a soldier
that was wearing that part of the bangle.
da. Ben is using her bangle
to actually open these portals.
And still the resources
from all these planets.
The Carol
Danvers says the places that we call home,
she's basically pulling a Galactus
sucking all the resources out of planets
to help the three
and it looks like one of the targets
is Prince John's planet here.
Aldana, who's being played by park.
So, June, a lot of people
recognize him in the trailers.
one of the jokes, too,
is that when they find out
that they have to go there and Captain
Marvel doesn't want to go
like she's kind of reticent is
because she had some accident in the past
and sort of cultural misunderstanding
where she accidentally got married. Him.
but during the events of the movie, he's
meant to be an ally to them.
we get a better look of her spaceship's
used as all the creature comforts talking
about goose, the cat, the falcon,
who actually activates the coffee machine.
That's kind of the running joke
about Falcon.
Like, yes,
they look like cats,
but they're actually very intelligent
beings and very dangerous.
Nick Fury even says hello
to Goose the cat like, Hey, how you doing?
So it seems like he's made up with Goose
after all these years.
Like, yes, you did take my eye,
but you're pretty handy in a pinch.
while they're catching up.
You see a couple of pictures of Monica
Rambeau and of her mother Maria Rambeau.
The rumor is we're actually going
to see a version of Maria Rambeau,
Captain Marvel from another universe
at the end of the movie.
not the same one from the A380 universe
in the Illuminati,
because Scarlet Witch killed
all those members of the Illuminati.
but I think part of the idea
is that in the movie
they'll explore the whole idea
of crossing between universes
because we're in the middle
of a multiverse saga
and we're building up to Avengers
secret wars
where all these different universes
collide.
I think that at some point
during the end of the movie, somehow
Monica Rambeau
winds up in this alternate universe
where her mother actually became
Captain Marvel, kind of like we saw during
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
but a different universe.
part of the other reason
why her mother, Maria Rambeau,
is important to the plot of the movie?
not only was she
a big character during the first movie,
but she was Captain Marvel's best friend.
If you remember during Wandavision,
when they referenced Captain Marvel
to Monica Rambeau,
she got kind of pissed off
and she didn't want to talk about it
like there was some kind of
beef between the two of them.
I think the
idea is that they have some bad history
because Monica blames Captain Marvel
for not taking care of her mother
during the five year time jump.
during the events of the movie,
I think they will also address how often
Captain Marvel
actually came back to Earth,
because it's kind of a running joke
in the fandom, like the character
who's never around but seems super popular
with characters like Ms..
Marvel, she's got the brand new costume
that we saw in the Ms..
Marvel Post-Credits scene.
They changed the Marvel Studios logo again
to incorporate the logos and costumes
of all three of the characters.
Like Ms.. Marvel,
Sash makes the s at the end
they're playing the same Beastie Boys
song.
The joke about this
and they used in the last trailer
too, is the beginning of the song
says, Don't tell me to Smile.
there's meant to be a bit of a meta joke
because when the first movie came out,
there were a bunch of people
that complained.
The Captain Marvel
as a character was not smiling enough.
So this is their answer to that. Like,
don't tell me to smile.
But using the Beastie Boys track
because it is also an intergalactic movie,
really big Easter egg here.
When Dar Ben calls Captain Marvel
the Annihilator big, a nihilist reference.
I've done a couple videos on a nihilist
because it was a big guardians
of the Galaxy three deleted scene with the
Originally James
Gunn was going to have him
be the person to create Rocket,
but then completely changed his mind.
It made the high evolutionary instead
the analyst character is a huge fantastic
four character.
He's from the negative zone which is a big
location is fantastic for comics.
They also featured in the 2015 Fantastic
Four movie
maybe we'll see him in the MCU
at some point as an overarching villain
in the Annihilation wave.
there are a lot of references
to that storyline in the comics
during the Guardians
of the Galaxy trilogy,
just because that's
where a lot of those characters
originally came from DA
Ben Finds the other Bangle.
The match for Ms.. Marvel's Bengal.
And if it wasn't clear Ms..
Marvel is still a mutant.
Without the manga, like she could
still have her powers without the bangle.
I think the idea is that the bangle
just enhances her abilities.
they pick up with that Ms..
Marvel Post-Credits scene
where they start switching places
and they actually edit in a way
that makes it seem like all three of them
are switching places at the same time,
not just two of them.
when you see Monica Rambeau
touching this barrier here,
that might have something to do
with destabilizing this universe,
the MCU universe
in why they teach an incursion happening
where she gets trapped in another universe
At the end of the movie.
Something about the bangle that Da Ben is
using to make her device to open portals
and steal resources from other planets
is destabilizing the MCU just in general.
we get a longer scene in Kamala
Khan's house where Monica Rambeau is
explaining exactly what happened
and how all their different powers work.
one of the big surprises
I've also heard recently
is that during the movie,
instead of calling Monica Rambeau Photon
or calling her Spectrum, one of her
comic book names, they'll actually refer
to her as Captain Marvel
like another Captain Marvel.
It'll be a play on the title.
The Marvels
because way back in the comics,
Monica Rambeau was technically
the first female captain.
Marvel was like the first woman to hold
the title of Captain Marvel for the vast
majority of her history in the comics,
Carol Danvers was known as Ms..
Marvel.
She became Warbird for a little while
with this costume
and a lot of people remember.
But then, relatively recently,
she switched to Captain Marvel.
So that's actually a pretty new thing
for the Carol Danvers character.
it as they explain they have to find a way
to use all three of their powers
in the quirk behind them
switching places to their advantage
during their big fight against Ben
which you see later in the trailer.
you notice
that she's falling through the air.
Kamala Khan has a t shirt
with a bunch of Captain
Marvel comics on it
that are from real life.
a lot of the artwork in her bedroom
is also based on real life comic book art.
it if it wasn't clear, they're actually a
bit of a costume change during the movie.
So this is them in the other suits
that they wind up getting later.
More comic book suits are more versions
of comic book suits
then when Captain Marvel says
Dear Ben is targeting all the planets
that they call home
and they go back to Earth,
it sounds like
they will come back to Earth
and they'll be another battle
of the saber space station here.
lot of humans on the space
station, too, behind him.
most of the time when we seen the space
station, it's been other skrulls
that have been working there
and you probably noticed
the Statue of Liberty has been repaired
since the events of Spider-Man.
No way home, because this is happening
well after Spider-Man, No way home.
when Monica is arguing with Captain
Marvel, saying you're not the only thing
standing between this and the universe,
she's trying to explain to her
that there are other people there
with powers who can help her.
They actually revealed recently
one of the reasons why Captain Marvel
has been away for so long or stays away
so long is because after she got rid
of the Kree influence on her mind
and got her memories back,
she remembered who she was.
She became a workaholic
and just spent all of his time
working around the galaxy
trying to help people.
so it's kind of like the working girl
that never takes time to come home
and visit her friends.
they had the joke
about an entire pack of working, like you
see a bunch of kittens which are just baby
flerkens goose the cat has been busy.
deal with a couple of funny moments,
but if there are any big Easter eggs
that you spotted in the trailer
that they didn't
talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Generally, I think this trailer
is a little bit better than the last one.
but like I said, the big concept
that they're teasing
during this movie is the incursions
becoming a bigger thing
because we're getting so much closer
to Avengers five, Qing Dynasty in Avengers
six, Secret Wars where the multiverse
begins to collapse on itself.
Blame Deadpool
for some of that happening too.
We'll see a lot of that idea
during Deadpool 3.
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but it's Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel
Universe.
there's a bunch of other trailers
that are coming this weekend
because of Comic-Con,
so be sure to enable alerts
for my channels. You don't miss that.
There should be an invincible Season
two trailer on Friday,
and I think we might get a Loki Season
two trailer as well this weekend.
whatever they wind up releasing,
of course they'll do videos for it.
So click here
for my brand new Secret invasion
finale trailer and click here
for all my other Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!